purgation is is five times worse than
food I knew who this guy was 20 years
ago I mean I mean I've watched I mean
he's he's always been there he's been
Putin's right-hand man since he was
president before that I mean they came
up together at St Petersburg uh and uh
what can you tell us about the the
essence of the Wagner group he heads
this but what's the whole purpose of
these guys it was a started uh 20 years
ago by Putin roughly as his own private
mercenary Army to kill people he wanted
killed inside Russia
uh with plausible deniability and then
to kill people around the world and to
go uh take over with mercenary forces uh
in the third world just like China and
the U.S does and take resources so they
go around in pillage uh and they uh also
uh assassinate people for Putin
and apparently they're currently in the
all over North Africa the Middle East
Syria they were the ones that helped
invade Crimea and they're all over
Ukraine right now